[Music]
things
coch
note is the habit does nothing more than pelé
and
louis
and 8
all
and
you are
uy
extra
[Music]
or not
to the payments
so
catch
well
that
this for well
com
de lawn
the market
its greenness of united
perhaps but caused
in time
vy good if replica in austin
or not
these three women and I can only more
impossible
with their colors of diesel and fine
city
in exchange right
there is one that will not interest me
or not
so I back
and
our
no
[Music]
yes
a part
[Music]
later
no
now it
's true
dent
hello
no
[Music]
I wouldn't tell
the story of this
and throw away
I was wrong
meters
neither I nor with him
young man
maybe there will be
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
guys
[Music]
well
no
and I
'm hello when I'm done
what happened the fix
is that [Musi
] and s
ude
t you c
me late
o no
no no mo
e that'
right no no
ah wh
n
Musi
] now h
said
1 because
[Music]
has
job
and
value
but I had to give a little
siam and countries
yes it
complicates words
and
queens
youtube
ah
the fishes
why
[Music]
personal life
according
to the bathroom
sad
yes
even
l
me
[Music]
yes
only for forrest three times
[Music]
no
longer
[Music]
yes yes
better
[Music]
when you reach this end let's go
yes
[Music]
look at this come on
thank you
I'm a
Muslim world
milk
and
ok
news
yes
after minister he had to kiss
end
europe
and
destroy me
jaume vallés you are
getting
management
what is this